hey everyone I'm Gabe Highland product
manager on swordsman we loved hearing
your excitement when you saw our
announced trailer and if you haven't
seen it yet you should check it out but
there was one comment we heard from many
of you where can we learn more about
swordsman well I'm here to share with
you why swordsman is the next great
martial arts MMO from humble beginnings
you'll take your fully customizable
character on an epic journey filled with
humor tragedy betrayal and heroism fully
voiced cutscenes bring cinematic flair
to the story and we've kept the original
Mandarin voice acting to maintain that
authentic Musha experience you've been
asking for and what's wooja without
exciting fights in swordsman combat is
responsive fluid and unlike other MMOs
it emphasizes skill over gear early in
this story you'll align yourself with
one of 10 legendary martial arts schools
each school offers a unique fighting
style based around weapons choose from
single and dual sorts chain whips battle
fans and even firearms as you level up
you can even chain together custom
combos at the touch of a button with the
power to create your own customized
fighting style your characters
capabilities will be uniquely matched to
your play style a Sun and Moon martial
artist feels like an assassin with quick
strikes and high mobility while a
Shaolin disciple demonstrates
unstoppable power behind every blow of
his staff
movement is also a key part of gameplay
you can explore the environment using
classic blue jaw techniques like jumping
over rooftops there are even fantastic
abilities like running across water
triple jumping and dashing across the
battlefield with superhuman speed
movement is critical in battle and
you'll need to use it to your advantage
all of this comes together in
swordsman's action-packed PvP modes in
arena pvp you'll have the option to make
gear purely cosmetic normalizing all
player stats that means it's all about
skill join up with your allies and work
together to overcome your opponents in
addition swordsman will launch with
three other PvP modes including
cross-server battlefield PvP for fans of
large-scale combat now let's be honest
you won't survive long in PvP if you go
it alone that's where guilds come in
guilds in swordsmen offer a ton of
rewards including gear and items that
can't be found anywhere else but that's
not all when you join a guild kill align
yourself with one of two factions
mercenaries or bandits each faction
takes on unique quests and minigames
including infiltration missions escort
assignments raids and more in swordsmen
your guild will be a crucial part of
your experience I hope you enjoyed this
in-depth look at swordsman it's our goal
to bring you the most epic and authentic
martial arts MMO ever but don't take my
word for it download swordsmen and check
it out for yourself we can't wait to see
you in the game
you